Thanks.
How's it going?
Awesome.
How's it?
Pleasure to meet you as well.
How are you doing today?
Oh, I have a double question.
Don't need to answer.
Appreciate you.
Appreciate you doing.
Yeah.
Okay.
No, just me for today.
Yeah, let me show you as well.
Are you in Tel Aviv as well?
Uh, 10.33 in the morning.
And I'm uh, central times on the US right now.
Uh, usually in San Diego, but right now I'm in Florida.
Um, yeah.
Yep, no, 100%.
Cool, cool.
I did not.
No, I'm fairly new to higher dose, joined on probably about six weeks ago now.
So still, yeah, anything that is before then pre-18.
a growth strategy at Haredos.
So we've got an agency that manages the out-of-count Sharma Brands.
Maybe familiar with them.
They've handled a few bigger counts.
But yeah, so I'm also the Sharma Brands.
Like Nick Sharma, he's got a podcast, pretty big in e-commerce space.
But yeah, so I'm pretty much the liaison between the agency vendors and our marketing and sales channels with the internal team and reporting directly to the CMO.
She brought me on the kind of head up those partnerships.
So we can ensure that all of our vendors are meeting the KPIs we need.
And so we can continue to grow year over year.
So it's got to been my big focus.
Hey, what's with me tonight?
How you doing?
No worries.
Totally understand.
Yeah, I know how it goes.
Yeah, yeah, yep, just like a regular.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh.
Cool.
Yeah.
Yep, for sure.
Totally make sense.
Now my first photo either worked with the handful of, I guess, Facebook reps at this level to help understand and direct the business to get to the next level of next tier Facebook considers and just grow on the channel.
So as far as important people to know, Ingrid, she is a CMO, a higher dose.
That would probably be the next point of contact to have on these calls or be grouped in.
Her availability is scarce so she does have a pretty busy calendar and it is harder to sync up with her.
So that's kind of where I come in for a lot of this intermediary communication connecting with dots making sure all the vendors or partners are communicated connected and how the resources they need.
But outside of her I would say Sharma Brands, the account manager on Meta,
probably some of their growth leads and some of the other resources they have.
So probably probably three or four more people on ongoing communication between the two parties that would be important to have on this communication report, which I think may have started that way.
I think I got added to an email chain to sync up with you guys in the first place.
So yeah, I think a lot of the parties may be already involved.
Yeah, six weeks ago.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
And that's may have been communicating with and they're probably just putting me in, yep, you know, just kind of getting me in the mix with you guys to start.
But as far as like the business direction, what we're kind of focused on this year has been a huge emphasis on top of formal growth.
We have noticed a consolidation of like not new reach and just the ability to reach new people.
So we want to expand beyond the markets we've already touched.
The brands have been around for a handful of years.
They're a decade plus at this point.
So there's been a market saturation there.
So they're just looking to make more and new people aware about the products and what they have to offer, looking to expand in other channels like CTV and OTT.
Also recently expanded in a half-loven, kind of just what most DC brands are pushing for.
In 2025 it seems so just looking for other opportunities to expand the ecosystem so that it makes more channels like Meta effective.
One thing we've noticed here every year is that Meta isn't as is in performing as strongly as it has for the brand previously.
Noticing some pullback so we shift the spend around Google's kind of our primary channel at this point.
I think mother definitely can be dominant.
It just needs the right assets and resources, which we haven't probably been providing.
There's, you know, some Confederate issues that need to be addressed.
I think the creative does get optimized and fluctuated frequently, but there may not be enough diversity and creative assets, may not be enough static images in the mix, different types of video assets.
Yep.
Uh, not, no, yep, media creatives and across multiple channels.
Uh, email retention as well, but they don't touch the website.
And we've got another partner for that.
You fun?
Um,
So I feel like meta specifically, know that I think that's pretty encompassing.
We're introducing an MM tool here in the next few weeks.
So that should be helpful in figuring out which of these channels are most impactful and incremental.
And we may be able to invest more in the meta, but really the opportunity we're looking to unlock here is like NetNewReach, dropping your attack and prioritizing the products that are going to give us the most opportunity to scale efficiently.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm on a cack is looking worse year over year, which is causing us to bring the scale down.
Still bad, yes.
Yeah.
Yep, Northmeam MTA tool.
Last click, conservative you.
Well, it clicks on the cruel basis, kind of as you're familiar with how the tool works, but last click, one day, attribution, I think, in more traditional terms.
Yeah, yeah, good.
Yep, yep.
for last click, yeah.
Well, that's the general.
I would say Cruel's more just based off of when the event happens, or I mean, not in the event happens when the click happens.
Yeah.
I guess, yeah, we'll make it last touch.
Yep.
You know, we do have a few product releases on the way.
We just dropped one last month that did fairly well with our existing audience and it's performing well on some paid channels also.
So we're going to continue to drop products.
But I would say like the most, you know, focal point is just reducing tack on the channel by touching that new eyeballs.
The LTV model is considered, but it is more of a one-time purchase kind of brand, very high AOVs.
The almost, I think, is like a $500, $600 AOV last little month.
So, you know, very, very high, I guess, cost, very high cost to entry as well.
So, we do have some subscription products that
We've introduced they're not like a primary driver, but it is starting to become a focal point of the business, but it's historically been OTPs.
It's been the focus, so yeah.
Yep, you know, except CTV, I think that's probably the only channel that they're not managing.
But yeah.
I think I'm five, six months now.
They came in earlier this year.
Yeah, relatively new.
Some probably marks around March and April's when they started working with higher dose.
Yeah.
I agree.
Yep, make sense.
I would say coming into the next call, I kind of have those key for insights ready to, you know, just workshop with Ingrid.
You know, that's probably going to be a big focal point for her.
And so, you know, that would be a good starting point for her to come in is you guys kind of having some, you know, recapping H1 coming into Q4.
It's some ideas.
Good introduction.
You know, now we've kind of got this little preliminary call out the way.
Cool.
Awesome.
Okay.
Yep, yep, nope, don't expect that, but yeah, just moving in that direction so that, yeah, yeah, for sure, yeah, cool.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, totally get it.
I know you guys are busy.
Yep, yep, yep.
One big unit.
All right, sounds good.
Awesome.
Okay, thank you.
Appreciate the time, Gras.
Enjoy your time.
And don't pledge a meeting as well.
Peace.
Yeah, like, I don't know why I haven't happened, but I got thrown into the mix lab, and I'm not a huge fan, but like, you know, like, you're doing a do-do-do-do-go.
Okay.
So many calls man.